peu ça alors je suis de retour pour les
commentaires du match de speech domine
donc il y a déjà une rose aujourd'hui
mais on est au deuxième match du jour
donc cette fois c'est entre anna vos
it-shoes qui est grand maître et yulia
au smac mètres d'un sol et toutes les
deux sont des joueuses ukrainienne donc
voilà ça va être ça va être intéressant
de voir ça donc ok alors là si une
française
donc c'était ça le début de 4,6 des
quatre des cinq cavaliers ces trois
poupées 4 et 5 ça c'est une mine hour
plutôt classique ou f8 sol et b6 je
connais pas trop je connais pas trop
cette ligne saint péens l'europe est
bizarre eu 5 v6 ou v8 super bizarre mais
bon mon avis je le connais donc ok donc
voilà si c'est passé en sont à cette
collision
ok donc piqué rock et g3 donc là
j'imagine les blancs maurice est debout
ch4 on essaie de faire halte 5 aussi
créé une attaque sur le petit rock ok
donc là mais il sait si oui il faut
faire h théâtre mon avis si nécessaire
surtout qu'elle a déjà préparé les g3
donc elle continue son plan tout à fait
normal et 6h 5h et son cas va y en a je
suis sceptique possible la pression
énorme et on est pas très très
confortable à jouer en tout cas moi moi
j'aimerais pas trop mais bon après si
c'est une joueuse de france elle doit
avoir l'habitude donc les coûts du genre
qui a veillé à 100 que c'est possible
donc bien sûr sur tours bien on prend b3
tout reprend il ya ces 4 et sinon après
qu'elle ait à 5,6 les blancs pouces b4 y
aura peut-être des primes sur la case c5
oil c4 ou alors peut-être ccap ica pib
trois de ces choses de ce genre là c'est
peut-être possible du coup au smac
réfléchit non toutes les deux rangs
passé beaucoup de temps déjà
alors que kate dans son aise en sont
seulement au 15e coup elle devant déjà
bas à new york il a déjà passé 2 minutes
sont donc ça fait beaucoup de rivaux
donc on dirait que la menace h 5 e il
fait vraiment peur
mais je pense pas qu'elles devraient
avoir si peur fait ça en tout cas en
tout cas il vaut mieux qu'à jouer vite
ok callas 5 c'est le coup dont aucune en
france est donc là h5 se moquer g de
beckham a troqué donc l'alluré peut-être
qu'à y avait trois au suivi de ces
quatre mais oui c'est vrai que ça a
l'air par la sosucam et y fera rien du
tout angle étroit donc en affaires oui
ça semble assez bons points 9 ans nous
pousser les autres
donc bien sûr la tour n'est pas prenable
quoi qu'il arrive parce qu'il y aura ces
quatre et l'a d'ailleurs c'est possible
de pousser ses quatre directement
d'accord c'est un choix si assez logique
de d'échangés ce que move et cavaliers
contre qu'on te fous qui est aussi
mauvais même mais le cas ben ali faisait
vraiment rien en b3 d'eau donc
donc oui c'est vrai il vaut mieux ne pas
s'en soucier
mais bon là là on dirait qu'il y aura
des petits soucis peut être h5 et
cavaliers f4 ce cavalli francs rien du
tout et je lui dis sera terrible on va
peut-être prendre ces cinq d'abord et
après parce que sur kayak calmy rey qui
a cessé car c'est sa prime donc ça ça
tient en main le jeu là si elle voit ses
quatre ça serait vraiment le regardera
un peu dans le jeu elle l'avait elle
table c'est pour ça que mozilla aurait
vraiment dû à ce moment-là prendre
d'abord avec le plan b et après faire
cailler f4
tout est fait à oliana absolument tout à
fait remis donc bon c'est pas trop
comment faire des problèmes
mais bon c'est l'énorme aussi ne peuvent
pas faire de progrès du tout donc si il
ya un an en descamps keith de gagner
c'est clairement lié les blancs qui
essaient de pousser mais bon c'est très
difficile vois pas vraiment comment
faire bien sûr faut essayer de faire
râler le roi mais ça valait savait
difficile de vraiment passé alors
wahhabite non je ne suis pas je ne suis
pas la sienne je suis originaire de
franche-comté
mais c'est vrai que mon club d'échecs
est amoureuse donc peut-être à cause de
mon accent c'est vrai que j'ai pris un
peu un peu l'accent alsacien comme quoi
j'ai passé du temps à mulhouse
grâce à mon club d'échecs mais mes dents
je suis originaire de franche-comté
donc étant telle tendresse est fait roi
a eu deux donc son but ça peut-être et
de pousser f4
plus tard peut-être qu'il va faire des
trucs du jour cavaye age 3 et 4 mais bon
ça c'est très difficile à passer vous
faisait qu elle veut juste caché son roi
l'album mais son rôle est peut-être y
aura des soucis avec dame à trois là bas
non ça a l'air d'aller en fait y aller
c'est le mets en b2 salle est ce à dire
qu'il n'y aura pas des lieux rapport à
mon idée parce que il ya toutes les
cases sont contre les bords des pions
blancs donc et pourra être vraiment
mettre son foulard et sa dame là pour
pouvoir contrer donc ouais sont rois
sera vraiment sécurité là en b2 si
j'essaie à son plan je sais je sais pas
si c'est ça son plein mais ça me
paraîtrait assez assez normal en fait
mais je pense qu'elle n'a pas trop le
temps d'y arriver en fait parce que le
temps qu'elle y arrive on aura peut-être
dans votre ok donc ff3 la f3 c'est
bizarre ça c'est assez bizarre est ce qu
elle veut passer la tour là-bas
peut-être où la dame la main pardon mais
dans ce cas là s'il voulait pas si la
dame il valait mieux faire trois directs
et après passé la dame comme ça parce
que là si elle fait un est là et doit
bouger avant de pouvoir par ceux là d'un
j'avoue que son coup et trois jours je
comprends pas
il ya peut-être des idées comme damas
trois s'il ya aussi elle protège d'abord
avec tours j'ai vite ou alors juste à
rien faire du tout rien faire du tout ça
devrait être assez
ouais je pense que ça s'est juste archi
nul parce qu'aussitôt que les membres ou
essaient de pousser à acheter sur a g6
d'un b200 mon choix pour preuve pour
empêcher la dame de venir à 3 ya je
pense qu'elles peuvent déjà voir
proposer l'annuler accepté mais mangou
gaillot reste plus que 20 secondes
donc c'est vrai que ça fait quand même
jouer parce que ouais mais bon dieu il
suffit juste de répéter les coups il ya
vraiment rien à y faire
voilà donc la et répète ok c'est bien
j'espère qu'est ce que veut gagner ça ou
pas ouais ok ok c'est seulement là donc
ok c'est mieux sinon bonjour docteur sur
youtube
comment vas tu
ok donc ça c'est une nouvelle page alors
bon soixante deux théorique mais je ne
connais pas apparence je pense que ça
doit être la grande ligne ou plus il y
aura des petites idées sur la colonne b
pour les blancs j'imagine
donc là le pion n'a pas l'air d'être en
gros souci s'il est prenable
voici des prix ça a l'air d'aller
tofu g5 là pour attaquer le cul en
recettes
ça a l'air normal et sûr et six bien sûr
c'est un gros affaiblissement sur la
diagonale
on peut juste revenir à la maison donc
fujisan salaires intéressants
en plus le fou est défendue par la dame
on n'a pas ce souci de ce côté-là sur
bel 5
on reviendra juste là il vous contera ça
donc
d'ailleurs le coup quelle affaire h3
elle voulait apparemment ils voulaient
vraiment empêcher ce fou g4 mais moi mon
adversaire je sais pas si je l'aurais
fait d'ailleurs sur mais bon entre
foulées saint cloud et 4 c à c'était
possible en fait faut que ça bouge et 4
passes qu'il y aurait là prise sur f3 on
sera obligé de reprendre avec l'option
ouais mais bon quand même en gagnerez
plus recette
ok bref revenons revenons à a longtemps
donc dames c'est cette menace rouge et
5,5 impossible mais il n'aime pas ce
qu'elle préfère rester dans les coûts
tranquille et faire faire des trucs du
genre d'homme des deux peut être aussi
attaqué ce pion faible sur ses six
peut-être faire tour c'est un écossais
et pousser des 5
peut-être aussi faire dame de deux
combats divers faut être quatre fois çi
s'il vous plaît je pense que là je
prendrai je prendrai les plantes ici la
belle joie
c'est un excellent dossier pour chasser
la dame mais c'est pas nécessaire parce
que ça ça détruit un peu la structure
document sa 5e ça donnerait la case des
cinq donc c'est pas ça passe c'est pas
donc là c'est mieux de juste à ta
question mais c'est vrai que peut-être
dans certains cas on peut quand même
poussé le 5
parce que c'est pas si grave de naira 15
mai mais bon c'est certainement sa
valeur toc toc n'ont pu s'y retrouvent à
le faire même nom un singe
donc là où le suspense donc peut-être
faire des trucs du genre tout rodez ans
et a fait faire une manoeuvre comme ça
ouais ça ne sert à pas mal fait ce que
veulent faire ça n roll over au nom
donc d'avis 2 quel est son plan quel est
son fond avec ce groupe pourra faire
dame 1 2
ben j'imagine voulait empêcher ces 5 et
attaquer bizarre mais ça va trop de sens
parce que dans tous les cas ces blocs et
donc je vois jamais trop ce qu'elle fait
avec dame 2 je pense qu'on verra ça
après qu'elle veut doubler les tours
c'est trop mais d'abord du ca va pas
trop s'en trouve d'allemand c'est le
fait un émule carrefour bekaert le
cheveux fous il faut des deux fauves et
4,3 j'imagine ce que sinon c'est super
bizarre ce qu'est 20 heures ouais je
pense qu'elle me faire ça donc
wendling à monible planes of wine women
who should be the best buy one l'a donc
en fête et voulais juste venir on a cinq
c'est tout c'était son plan de venir en
a cinq on peut dire qu'elle va fouet
mais le film c'est que maintenant si
elle fait un truc du genre foufou d2 il
y aura ces 5 7 5
donc ça pas trop trop simple de feu de
ne créer du contrôle juillet
5 ouais c'est logique c'est logique mais
j'ai tout mon coeur de youyous de la
poussée celle 5
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'arrive pas
trop à contrôler sa longue imaginant
coup comme ça et après il va essayer de
pousser ces cinq banques et ça aussi
c'est possible en affaires je n'accepte
pas les échanges de dames donc la
poussine ce que c'est possible parce que
sur la reprise y aura fou prend f3 et
aux curieux 5 va tomber ce qui sera très
grave
facebook a donc là je pense que les
plans sont déjà super mal il risque d'y
avoir des trucs du genre c4 pour bloquer
la position après le cavaly qui bien
baissier 117 les menaces à l'endroit ça
donne rien du dos ça ne m'aurait rien
parce que ya pas assez de gaz pour
impayés
j'ajuste pas ces pièces elles sont
surtout on va les placer disons que la
dame ne peut pas vraiment arriver à
temps donc par exemple en fou comme à
chier ça me bloque tout je pense qu'il y
aurait peut-être voulu enfin ça aurait
été mieux de faire ces quatre d'abord
parce que ça imite les trucs du jour qui
est pro mais si ce qu'ils peuvent être
enfermé dans donc d'abord ses cafés
après h 6 mai mais bon du coup là je
pense qu'elle va vraiment essayer de
faire un truc comme ça pour se sauver
c'est pour ça qu'elle réfléchit
d'ailleurs à y réfléchir et passion elle
vaut rsa direct au smac
elle pense vraiment des coups comme ça
elle a pas envie de venir en f3 ça c'est
sûr même si elle vient on est froid et
abat ok donc elle a fait cet épisode
f-16 donc apparemment bon le truc et la
russe était que surtout quand il faut
prendre 6 mai sur wii pon et veut faire
être fou pour un site j'imagine donc ok
ça peut se tenter oui sur une partie et
tout peut arriver surtout en bits donc
oui c'est vrai que c'est une bonne idée
d'avoir tenté ce genre de ce genre de
coup c'est bien mieux que de revenir à
la maison f3 et rien faire et attendre
attendre de perdre dé sa prose ya plus
tenter ici c'est peut être intéressant
mais bon sur des cinq j'imagine que là
il ya ces casques en fait qui bloque la
diagonale et du coup sûr la prison
réussisse il y a trois ponts et la case
des cinq est contrôlé par le fou et
enfin deux variantes
donc après 3.6 il y aura foule ces deux
et après qu'avait iphone 5 qui défend
aussi le pion g6 et tout les cas sous
entendez donc là là quand on a dit c'est
exactement cette ligne sur fou c'est de
l'iac et les 1er 5
donc c'est ça a l'air terrible terrible
problème pour lyon pour les bancs
ok donc elle est tenante vraiment tout
ce qu'elle peut sur un coup comme dame
g6 qui manas marty y aurait simplement
d'un des six l'imaginons ok donc elle
ça manque là
adam de six mois mais laure leroy bas
juste venir sans se cacher là
ok peut-être lkp mais y aura la prise
ça l'a vraiment moche ça très très très
proches
ouais donc là on peut vraiment tout
faire un cadeau on peut faire ça on peut
faire ça peut même caché le roi je pense
c'est ce qu'elle a fait
donc surtout repent autour point auquel
a pas fait ça la fesum ouais donc la
gare en trio avec deux menacés note faut
défendre contre les gros cela s'avère
difficile on a tourne pas vraiment venir
défendre parce qu'il y aura tous
conscients et surtout reprend ses huit
il y aura mon policard d'un meuble de
nos coeurs ok donc là je rentre au pays
a ok n'en vendons jeune maman j'ai dit
non sorte voir faire d'un f2 pous tio
proche de 6 donc ok peut-être faux
projet de loi ça pouvait se tenter mais
bon elle lape avait aussi vu le temps
des bleus a vraiment besoin de prendre
de risque avec ce genre de coups donc ce
genre de sacrifices donc vous irez faire
un petit échange de dames et elle et
blanc ont perdu autant donc annaba un
point et demi contre 0.5
donc c'est un français c'est la même
marion de bizarre que tout à l'heure
avec ben si c'est fou les fuites
semblent pousser un peu bizarre je sais
pas quel trou sans fond de jeu ça
ok donc là peut être il ya des poussées
h4 se vident h5 qui peuvent être
intéressantes aussi boum c'était bien vu
ce qu avait eu deux pour pouvoir faire
ces trois mais là j'ai vraiment envie de
pousser h 4 h 5 donc si on pousse h4 sur
les noirs répondrons par h5
j'imagine mais j'accepte avec le pouce
et moi on la sait plus trop possible
parce que le fou le fouet le cavaly
défendre
ça c'est normal pour moi c'est normal au
[Musique]
canton c'est ça la question
cabaye d2 pour défendre seule solution
peut-être mais bon ça paraissait pas
vraiment une menace
ça parle trop et une menace parce que
bon ça ça la dame se défend et après ses
quatre enfants simplement donc mais bon
cahier des deux ça va être intéressant
en cas de poussée 900 f 4 ou 5 ans on
peut faire ça
ok fossé 2 donc ça enlève toutes les
possibilités de de fourchette
ok alors on faire là j'ai toujours envie
de pousser h4 mais je pense que ça doit
pas trop marché enfin la la ça marche
pas clairement pas trop parce que il y
aura la prise après le foot va reprendre
mais en général peut-être bleus préparé
par jet fois h4 donc effectivement grâce
sur l'autre le trompe l'oeil et au caire
d'un n'ont pas d'enfant c'est france et
obligatoire je pense
avant même la casse des 4 lei fait mieux
avec le cas ricco aurait le calibre
meilleurs comme ça
les mini robes et 4 ou alors ouais la
vie revient et après il ya peut-être à 5
et kerry b4 ça a l'air pas la première
fois qu'on fait du coût est beaucoup
trop faible
mais pour aussitôt que les noirs vont
faire un petit rock au hockey wen en
fout bien mon petit rock qui est en
panne
elle donne la frousse est bizarre c'est
bizarre de données il faut il pas
revenir en f1 ambiant à parce que le cas
elle y est fort c'est peut-être pour ça
parce qu'elle pense que lecavalier en b
4 est plus fort que son fou en d3 mais
quand même ça me paraît assez logique de
prendre et après peut-être de pousser m6
voilà donc la prendre et après à préfère
faire un petit somme paraît correct pour
les blancs et leurs parents elle veut
pas prendre
ok elle veut jamais prendre
well on fait peut-être un tackle deux
fois fois repoussé b5 telle qu'elle peut
prendre ici écossais b5 mais nos
salaires bien ça lui a vraiment top
simplement donc elle a réussi à vraiment
se libérer je pense que c est une belle
position rigolo
c'est pas si facile de se défendre comme
ça si avec tout ça à 5 y aura des cas
très bas
oui il y aura b4 et après il y aura
foule et 5 qui arrive
lang lasalle est un salaire difficile
pour les blancs là peut-être à m6 qui
peut arriver mais bon ça avec le plan b
4 peut potentiellement être mais là bien
sûr c'est pas prenable du tout parce que
y aurait eu vous en faut deux donc c'est
ce qu'elle a décidé de faire tout de
suite donc tour prend peut-être la tour
ces trois là tous rentrés ils attaquent
le cul en b3 ou alors juste un peu juste
pour doubler tour tout simplement
cependant avec la tour c'est bien parce
que dans certains cas elle peut faire
des trucs du genre ça on essaie
d'obtenir avec le cavaly en france et 5
mai mais bon ça prend du temps
il ya peut-être d'un de mes singles qui
attaquent le pion et qui contrôlons qui
empêche le cahier de mire
toutfou 10,8 pour attaquer pour
continuer à attaquer le cul en hausse à
5 h théâtre ok ok donc elle est venu en
relève 5 et prendre le faut donc bien
sûr s'il le faut bougera ce moment là
mieux le puits en d4 sera faible
donc j'ai trois ça aide juste je sais
pas pour la fessée ou g3 ça n'a pas de
sens parce que dans tous les cas le
cavaly rallier à lyon en livre saint le
cul donc joué j'ai trois salles et ça
est juste le cac va y aller quel
lecavalier à y aller
donc là il y aura la prison en 3 way
suivi de chants du coup comme ça comme
dam dam des trois pour rentrer en c2
seniors pas mal
elle l'a fait
sur cavaillon on y aura sûrement tours 6
grâce au cloud âge la date n'a pas
prenable
oumou fougères solaire funds faut juste
un clin attaque le client est roi donc
elle sera obligée de se défendre avec
avg 2 et après il ya toujours ces deux
mais c'est faux y a pas de dépenses
tout ça doit tout simplement
donc là peut-être qu'elle peut faire
tout resserrement rentrée sur la
première rangée et et faire des choses
ouais continue à faire des choses peut
être tour à tour à chambrer après
ramener sur le tour en c1 on a bon sens
avec la partie contre on sait pas tout à
fait fini
oh
alors que faire telle qu'elle peut faire
dernière 5
elle pouvait faire d'un médecin je crois
parce que sur des rêves 5 cavalli là et
pouvait prendre et après rentrée en h3
et je pense que ça aura été matt très
vite mais l'a pas fait du couquet région
est ok elle essaie de pousser les
plantes c'est bien c'est une bonne
stratégie
ouais donc là il ya juste un chouïa
juste d'un médecin qui après sa mort
j'ai moi même j'ai même pas pour elles
réfléchissent myopathe
elle peut aussi faire dans ma chance et
il veut mais je pense que ça c'est juste
notre eau lagaf attends attends poêle à
pétrole
elle pouvait juste une partie directe ok
on a quand même elle a quand même réussi
à fermer et c'est qu'on fait et c'est
compliqué la vie pour absolument rien
quoi ouais mais bon c'était que ça
allait quand même c'était quand même
mieux que tu coules réfléchissez preuve
elle a fait un super sacrifices alors
qu'il y avait juste ma tante trois voies
avec des couples avec découdront
donc ok donc ça va donc c'est comme ça
il affirme plutôt dénudées des deux
côtés
ok alors bon ça sonne ça vous semble un
peu des positions de plus de système de
loin d'ailleurs sauf que ce que le
poulet pain f4 mais c'est ça ressemble
s'assemble
donc bon ce genre de police ont
peut-être qu'elle peut faire des trucs
du genre d'un mât 3 et essayer de
pousser ses 5 pouces et b4 peut-être
kayak a donc avait forcé les change
d'âme
ok tu vois intéressant donc à es17 était
obligatoire parce que ce moment on
menaçait cavaillé b6 on ça pour ça
qu'elle appelle ça prend dans ses cartes
seraient mauvais parce qu on prend juste
et moi on arrive à se dédoubler
donc ça serait bien pour les blancs
quelqu'un peut tenter des trucs du genre
fou mais quatre pour attaquer ce plan
est s'il vous mon continue de me petit à
petit plan avec elle et ses cinq
peut-être mais auquel elle est la fille
ligne un peu plus solide
donc c'est pas si facile de jouer pour
les blanches pense que là je préfère les
noirs quand même foi sans une enclave
choisi fauves et 4 est achevée il faut
un simple donc à presse après le v6 le
peu de demande quel est son plan hockey
qu'elle peut faire respecter jean fabbri
si c'est le cas
boitant donc elle a quand même pris la
crise fait faux bécasse mais du coup on
est un peu en retard
donc sur calais prend bien sûr on prend
avec le fou il y aura peut-être bézis
empêche la prise du pont à celles
après faut voir faudra y revenir et noir
pourront peut-être pousser ses 5 ou à
simplement je pense que c'est pas très
très bien pour les bleus c'est pas top
top
wii fit donc ça permet les échanges de
pièces en iowa en plus une lumière
police ont pour les blancs n'ont que
très peu juste prendre avec le hand le
cavalier en 17 est bon du coup là c'est
obligé de reprendre et peut-être lui
aura fo prend la fuite
même la structure depuis on n'a toujours
pas en très très bon pour les bancs dont
moi je prendrais clairement les noirs y
c'est simple concepteur et essayer de
pousser nous sacrifions enfin après
peut-être faire défaut mais fou et enfin
elle a fait tout de suite d'airs hockey
mom est ici pour réfléchir s'il n'y a
pas des c5
à mon avis ça ça ne marche pas trop
parce que ça ouvrirait la les lignes
pour pas grand chose
attends je vais le voir en pâtissent à
marcher c'est 5 1 mais je peux pas me
dommage je veux pas revenir en arrière
ok donc là peut-être c5 est poussive et
4 donc c'est ça qu'est ce que ça marche
ou pas non l'ordi l'apa l'ordi dit que
surprise cab est tombé 4 il dit que
c'est pas bien donc on va l'écouter on
va pas perdre 7 5
l'ordi dit qu'on devrait faire des coups
comme à 6 mai way up à elle l'a fait si
elle a trouvé m'a écouté ok donc à 6
alors bon on peuple est repoussée 7 5
okc amd 2,7 pouces et ça ou alors juste
pour passer le cabri
fou d'elle c'est bizarre wayne justin tu
as quelqu'un et si aussi les noirs
pousseur hk j'imagine je veux faire j'ai
quatre mois c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait
ça
donc oui j'ai quatre salles et un moment
ici parce qu'on veut pas trouver ouvrira
la colonne h
il vaut vraiment mieux la bloquer
oh sois super bizarre extrêmement
bizarre
c'est juste c'est juste une grosse
erreur en fait parce que là du coup elle
ouvre la colonne et il y aura des fois
je crois aussi des problèmes sur la cage
et 2 je sais pas trop pour elle a fait
ça le fait de jouer à laquelle la case
la clown chez sal est pas du tout parce
que son attaque elle est halal halal
elles dame faut vraiment pas qu'elle
ouvre là le côté droit parce que c'est
s'est passé là où les noirs ne l'attaqué
pas les bons du coup là j'imagine la
ligne noire y aura en doublage de tours
qui va arriver bientôt
et ben récit de rentrer en g2 donc là je
pense qu'elle se rend compte
progressivement que c'est apparemment
fois c'est quoi qu'elle sait pourquoi
elle réfléchit temps
donc là il y avait un truc qui arrive
tout simple en taille que le meilleur
choix ça serait d'essayer de pousser au
centre une demande par exemple prendre
d'abord et après essayer de pousser
parce que bien sûr débout comme qu'avec
des deux pour faire trop cher ça
marchera jamais parce que c'est pas
c'est assez rapide y aura toujours tour
au g8 et la tour qui va rentrer en jeu
deux dons qu'elle a réfléchi et
réfléchie rappelles tu vois la russie le
4 ok donc bon ça risque d'être assez
faible peu après la prison et cap
peut-être tour g4 qui arrive si les
pions en l'air d'être une faiblesse je
suis plus que d'autres
surtout après une après la prise d'ici
tu as peut-être aussi c5 qui peut qui
peut être possible après la prise donc
des points 4 elles feront et après ce
coup c'est simple
surtout que ça créera aussi une fable
sur la case aux 5 oui ça c'est bien dit
ça c'est cool aussi
donc on peut prendre peut-être et après
pousser ses cinq quand même
ou alors le fer direct ce qui est
peut-être encore mieux parce que ceux ci
elle prend déjà un tube endroit prendre
mais cavani bougé après on prend donc en
dessin que c'est plutôt cool
salaire morts archi mort pour les blancs
semblent peut-être aussi f5 qui peut
être possible
peut-être prendre d'abord et la préposée
f5 ça peut se tenter
ouais c'est ce qu'elle vaille c'est de
faire ce qu'elle fait f5 tout un roi des
6 1 mais y'a plein fouet non mais
toujours aussi c'est un brouillard
redescendant s'écoule voilà c'est tout
raymond gagnant ça qu'est ce que
j'aurais dû faire demi-tour un
cafouillage ici ordi mais c'était news
pas bio coûte à 17h entrée rancourt
hockey à est donc là c'est fini c'est
fini et halo proches rejettent ils ah
oui voilà la tour qui tombe c'est en
cauchemar le pion qui arrive qui va à
dame
donc c'est fini
et je pense qu'ils auraient une toute
petite pause ici parce qu'en général il
ya toujours on posera la mi-temps à la
mi-temps de d&d 5 e +2 donc c'est le
moment de la pause je pense qu'on va
voir si c'est le cas si c'est le cas
alors je vais aussi faire une petite
pause
donc on dirait bien que c'est le cas
donc bon bah je vais faire ma toute
petite pause et je vais être de retour
dans 5 minutes environ à tout dit
donc les parties viennent de reprendre
et je suis de retour
donc voilà donc et songe bel a même
ouvert sur que d'habitude avec avic b6
et il faut aux foules foyer fuite
maintenant
cette poussée des cinq bons alors faire
cesser ce cas et c7
peut-être qu'on a le cavalier ans elle
sait ce qu'elle a à faire croquer
pousser aussi
tout ce qu'on peut faire j'ai castro
c'est d'ailleurs sur cave elle est là on
fait d'un des trois n'attaque le cabinet
hawkeye et voulait le bouger et après il
y aurait eu g5 peut-être en bois n'ont
peut-être pas en fait
baïocco c4 s'alarme à 5-4 salaires point
sur la prise bien sûr il y aurait eu sa
donc là c'est pour ça qu'à la fac y
traits qu'on peut faire des coups comme
dam des trois qui surtout attaque ce
cavalier en a six
donc ça menace la prison des 5 ok ça
c'est pas mal mais ouvrir le centre je
sais pas si c'est vraiment ce qu'on veut
faire c'est douglas et donne vraiment
une faiblesse à que les noirs peuvent
intégrer
donc là c'est un assez bon coup parce
que bien sûr c'est pas prenable à cause
de cavalli et wayne et noir de défendre
ce cavalier parce qu'elles sont il y
aura la prise si peut-être fou g51j si
c'est le cas tant qu'elle veut bien
défendre et menacé de prendre ici où
l'on comprend bien sûr c'est qu'on peut
même faire qu'à lui aussi souci pour
essayer de rentrer dans le match soit
sur les cases
donc cavalier faut compter 5 avoué
prendre qu'avec des 4 suivi de cavani je
sais 5 c'est pas mal ça va pas mal de
dos je pense qu'elle devrait tendre
dessin
ouais je pense qu'elle est quasiment
obligé de prendre parce que sinon il y
aura vraiment des grosses menaces si
elle fait rien oui mais il y aurait eu
faux prend il suffi t elle de cinq lots
cariou rites et enlève cette filière
donc ouais elle a bien fait et là je
pense qu'elle va laisser faire psa s'est
réconcilié plus tard ou alors pas
forcément en fait non parce que sur
lequel et c'est ça que tu auras b4 donc
bon ça dépend aussi de ce qu'elle fait
ça dépend de ce que la dame fait saddam
voilà y aura calmé 3 bien sûr si la dame
dans un 4 faut réfléchir je pense que
les changes de dames sur l avantage d
des blancs parce que du coup peut-être
qu'ils vont pouvoir faire dès qu'elles
ont menées en veillant à m6 mes médecins
il n'y a pas trop de deux possibilités à
part les changements
enfin on peut faire ses systèmes en
salle et de femmes au centuple aura tout
retourné en carrière
donc auquel donc dans mon avocate c'est
peut-être ça n'est pas moi
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs le
meilleur parce que bien sûr d'un ancien
ça marche pas à cause de kayes médecin à
temps quoique d'un petit encas et b3 il
ya tel cas les projets 6 en fin de
grille en tout le monde par exemple
dames m23 qui répond à un écailler pour
le ciss vrai ça a l'air pas mal ça
s'avère comme elle est aussi dans
certains cas on peut même faire damas je
crois donc disons çà çà çà çà et après
il ya damas je crois qu'ils attaquent et
2,6 et qui attaque et h7
mais du coup il a choisi d'échanger les
dames la place ce qui est j'en reste
sans doute le plus le plus cadeau
donc là si les nord de fort bien
l'amener à cette fac n7 faire d'un match
qu'à celui de qu'avait lieu café
oups c'est cavalli et 6
donc là je pense qu'il faut prendre pour
faire d'un prend donc la sueur d'un
promeneur a response rendre avec le cas
et c'est ou lequel j donc peut-être
c'est mieux de prendre avec le cas
légers parce qu'il sera peut-être un peu
exposé en rangée cinq groupes en tête
fait appeler on voit peut-être en 9,6
avec sully plutôt que de d'enlever ce
bon défenseur mais bon là il a réfléchi
ce toutes les deux très longtemps donc
là oui bon mais la fille et l'a choisi
de paille changer le drame du coup il y
aura des matches 4 avec un gros avantage
surtout car il y aura damage qu'à celui
de b4 et après cavalli key card celui
qui assiste
elle a fait on a vu un fait donc la
prétaille cavalli ses qualités 3 il y
aura tourné en est ou alors juste je
suis juste qu'un 4 ouais donc là elle
peut faire et peut-être même faire
quelques uns tout de suite mais bon il
vaut beaucoup mieux faire tourner ont
d'abord et après en prenant mais leur
cabine à la case m6 est totalement haut
niveau et un et pas défendu donc donc ça
sera assez simple dans de longs on est
là
donc là peut-être cas ici à 4
bien sûr pas logique parce que c'est
roger la page 4 du coup la lettre du
coup on emmène suis là bien sûr et après
on l'emmène en épices sur cavani l5 ont
peut-être le petit n'avait recueilli 6
quand même tout sur tout rond elle prend
donc à me prendre là et pendant et après
il y aura toujours des temps pendant
l'allaitement
on peut très facilement de faire enfin
c'est simplement par km donc là il ya
une infection non car si si c'est juste
gagnant pour les blancs c'est juste fini
en fait aucun mal n'a pas fait de moi je
pourrai mais bon c'est que c'est quand
même gagné parce qu'elle va faire payer
6 au prochain
c'est pas une très grosse faute
autrefois
donc aussi on se rappelle que le cavaly
b3 et aussi en l'air mais on n'aura pas
trop besoin de qui les a certes vous me
faire détruit le genre caiap 6 ce
qu'elle a fait cette heure qui avait
rachète ac a été attaqué la tour et
après on prend le cas vaillant baies 3,5
pouces elle peut encore essayer de tenir
avec cavaliers d2 mais après il y aura
qu avec 8,4 en f1 et tous font des huit
sûr d'un point il ya cahier points à 6
c'est la fourchette royal donc ça c'est
fini et au bar fihri mais là il ya du
kouyate au fond dit
ok donc ça s'annonce bien pour anna elle
a trois et demi contre un an et demi
donc très bon début pour elle et il
reste 20 août 20 minutes pour la fin de
la première phase qui est du 5 + 2 et
après on passera en 3 + 2
ok donc la sinne l'ouverture anglaise
ça ressemble aussi à un déchet matsinhe
farming savez quand j'ai un peu plus tôt
des trucs du genre f carte plutôt que h4
donc ça c'est une anglaise c'est assez
marrant la structure d'ailleurs qu'ils
avaient avec le pion h4
pendant qu elle est agressive et veut
vraiment gagner parce que les gens elle
est déjà mali aux planches elle aurait
elle sait qu'elle a besoin de gagner ça
donc peut-être quatre je pense que
c'était une faute de faire j'ai quatre
ouais il va bien mieux valait mieux
prendre et j'ai cassé super bizarre
parce que le pion à super faible way you
on peut faire des trucs du genre
simplement se développer comme ça par
exemple ont mené le four 3 essayé de
pousser des carottes
town d4
effroi car c'était possible pour faire
cavalier absinthe qu'après mais non elle
n'a pas fait et là c'est un peu trop
tard parce que parce que vu que la
colonne des ouverte maintenant il y aura
des problèmes sur des six mètres mais ça
peut tuer en faisant des f4 mais du coup
je pense que ça sera fou pour 1,4 pour
tomber sur le cavalier ces six là il
faut imams y avoir des trucs du genre
cavalli mais 5 pour attaquer le plan des
six quais ont encore attaqué le femme en
voile aurait vu juste juste se
développer admettre une tour en d1
donc maintenant bien sûr f 3 400 ans
plus tard parce qu'à chaque fois il y
aura fou prend les quatre qui attaquera
le cul le cavalier seul
je vois pas trop de bons pour points
noirs ici sur assist qui se passerait
sur aussi nordine grand roque
mais pour attaquer il n'aime pas ceux
qui ont des sites imiter la table dit
gros rock clairin ok donc là est là et
je rédigeais toujours à la page mais à 6
tel que l'a mieux ça serait de prendre
en d4 et après sur fou prend faire 5
fg trop vraiment trop c'est vrai faut
vraiment pas faire ça elle a déjà
réfléchi mais entre en ondes au 14e coup
cette pâte of donc la france est
nécessaire pour empêcher un poids pour
attaquer le cavalier ans à 6 c'est ce
qu'elle va faire
et aussi parce que sur calvi prend 24
j'imagine qui aurait peut-être eu l'idée
des cinq donc en prenant avec le fou ça
stoppe cette idée aussi
mais ça ça stoppe pas tant que ça en
fait s'il veut si elle veut faire des
cinq a toujours fait redescendre
ok donc elle a bien fait donc oui on est
quasiment obligé de prendre parce que
sinon il ya des français 4 donc on doit
prendre des 5 et prend après le foot
doit repartir à la maison et j'aime pas
il faut en fait pour les bleus ronsin je
pense qu'il y aura des primes sur la kdf
5 donc imaginons que si on prend et
prend fou bouge
il y aura peut-être qu'à manille est
simple web 5 ce genre de choses donc ça
peut être problématique
mais bon c 'est le mieux c'est mieux
rien parce que si on bouge le fou sans
prendre des cinq d'abord il y aura il y
aura des franges c4 ce qui sera assez
assez gras je joue un patron pour un
réfléchi si on partait qu'elle veut
faire un truc du genre fou ici peut-être
et sur la ferrand cette sacrifier le
client en fait ça serait pas si mal car
un truc du genre foule ses deux sacres
ip durand fall mans encaissait 2007 oui
de créer des contrôles jeux à 2 contre
jeu avec les pièces ça peut être pas si
mal mais bon du coup elle réfléchit
longtemps toutes les deux ils ont
réfléchi tellement longtemps
ok donc en a pris elle allait pour le
coup et le coût le plus solide
ok donc la laque ne peut être peut être
comme pour les noirs qui peuvent faire
un truc du genre tour 8/15 cinq ou six
d'abord protéger le plan dassin qu'un
prêtre ça mais c'est vrai que à cause du
pion des cinq je pense que c'est
peut-être quand même avantage pour les
blancs parce que elles peuvent assez
facilement attaquée la tts option
donc là je vois pas trop de bons coups
pour les noirs ci-contre du genre cavaye
l5 y aura toujours à la prise a sévi de
l'appréhender sans s'alarmer
donc peut-être tour à tour pour créer
des brèmes sur fo qui bouge là ouais
ouais bon moi j'ai cette audi sal a pas
mal on y fait
après on peut faire des derniers
décamètres aussi mettre la pression
dans des cas vraiment pas un salaire
très très très fort en plus la balle qui
va reliant et fils sont suivis de fouet
fouet car c'est mortel c est mortelle il
n'y a pas de défense je crois d'hommes
d'hamdi d'un même site celui de fouet
aux 4 c'est quasiment fini parce que ça
a confié lecavalier et puis c'est
difficile surtout après vos quatre la
fougasse roman sur ô surprise il ya tôt
prendre pour pandémie tu dessines ans si
le roi bouge oui il ya dame prend 1,6
ce qui est encore pire donc ouais ouais
donc cette partie finit bien donc c'est
bien pour eux et qu il ya assez bien
remonté avec cette partie et il reste 10
minutes encore après ça sera l'heure du
3 puces de hockey donc cinq ans une
française je pense qu'elles vont encore
jouer la ligne avec ben si c'est fou et
fuite n'a l'air d'amis elle a l'air
danoise a donc encore une fois c'était
sa prépa spéciale pour ce match mondiale
on va cavaillonnais c'est normal mais
aussi pour pousser ses caps donc c'est
vraiment similaire à ce qui a été jouée
avant sauf que avant j'avais fait foi
cette ce qui permettait à google à anna
pardon de pousser ses quatre heures
cette fois elle n'a pas permis à vue
qu'elle a fait dans des sacs qui
contrôle la casa 4 donc là il a été
forcé de jouer ces trois élus fois
l'horreur en fait mans 2-2 contre je
fais exact c'est exact ouais
du coup là tu veut parier sur les crêtes
à suivre tes sur deux fait de gagner
quoiqu'il arrive
donc là je pense qu'elle a vraiment bien
amélioré salon ioulia elle a bien
amélioré parce que du coup la police
envoie très fermé et il n'y a pas trop
de moyens de lui de faire des progrès
très calme faisant des trucs à l'oeil
droit avec avec g3 et et h4 mais ça
prendra beaucoup de temps
ça c'est bien c'est bien du coup elle
peut faire tête des chaussures comme fou
ou g5 peut-elle être way avoir des trucs
comme ça
bon j'ai l'impression que la paix la
position peut s'ouvrir du côté noir
bientôt f6 voilà prendre quelque chose
là mais plutôt faire et 6 donc elle
tente un peu son plan avec h4 sénat de
serre doit pas pauvre sel on a obligé
mais parce que sinon on ne peut pas
vraiment faire de progrès
ok donc à essayer de faire des trucs à
l'aide au plus tôt au centre du coup
mais avait peut-être fait qu'après ça il
peut même missile de fer et 6 ou alors
ils essayent de rentrer avec l'apport
moyen tour 50 c'est ce qu'elle a fait et
peut aussi dans certains cas faire des
trucs comme ça mais mais plutôt par le
plus juteuses logique celle de c'est de
faire tout retour s'est vite essayer de
doubler et on va entrer dans ces deux
êtres aussi faire d'homme à homme là on
peut faire tous à 8 way et après demain
car peut-être
donc il ya eu lieu en jeu c'est parce
qu'elle keita j'imagine que justement
trouvé cette case
mais ça a l'air mieux pour innocent je
pense que perso je prendrai les noirs
ici à cause du coût entre os de la
colonne csa l'a quand même massira cia
défi efficace
donc elle a bien fait d'un magasin donc
bon pour le moment c'est vrai que c'est
pas simple de trouver des menaces et
qu'elle peut essayer de mettre son cas
mais qui se terre paraît grand chose de
le ramener en jeu avec cavaliers f5
peut-être d'abord bouger le fou qu'elle
me paraît après par camille au 7ième 5g
que ça peut se tenter mais du coup là
qu'avec des 3l venir en v2 elle peut
venir en b2 mais c'est pas très grave
parce que sur calais b 2 ans prendra en
c1 et après le pion à 3 sera faible
donc il sera juste prenable donc ça a
l'air pas mal ça va mal pour prenez pour
les noirs il n'y a pas trop de soucis
d'ailleurs hausse est même possible de
faire tour ces deux peut être
tous deux lords il aime pas l'ordi la
pâture ces deux passes qui dit qu'il ya
tout reprend ses deux tours reprend et
d'amd 1 donc il y aura le clouage et à
cause de ça ils aiment pas donc il dit
pour ces deux c'est pas enfin ok qu'est
ce que je veux faire avec ce cavalier
peut-être qu'elles veulent passer comme
ça parce qu'elle veut faire ce qu'elle a
vu le camion la fuite
après qu'elle veut faire comme ça après
tout c'est bessin et qui font que ça
enfin faire b6 et ses cartes mais ça
prendra beaucoup de temps
comme l'a peut-être oui parce que si on
va en b3 en coulisses et et la dame
aurait été été mal après dans le métro
il ya caillaissé en masse est finie la
dame reste on tape complètement enfermé
donc c'est bien pour elle qu'elle n'ait
pas fait ça
ok donc ça y'a perdre échange là tout
plein des changes
je pense qu'elle a fait le bon choix
parce que fallait pas vraiment laissé
aller si les noirs prendre le contrôle
la case des cinq surtout pas tout de
suite mais d'abord faisons tout comme
kelly g6 pourrait changer la première
paire de cavaliers et après m'être en
payant des impôts donc c'est ce qu'elle
a voulu éviter c'est pour ça qu'elle à
pousser les pions
ok ok donc on a donc son âme mais celle
j'imagine que la dame va revenir à
proposer les changes
ce moment là
ça va peut-être ou la sai a nommé n'ya
pas ceint d'un fil à tour et serait en
l'air ok donc une dame d'un mais c'est
peut-être possible à mais il y avait
peut-être dame
wait and bess shebab pour la part fait
un peu dingue 27 avec l'ambiance a
attaqué le fou s'attaquer la tour ça tu
es quelqu'un savait faire de marché mais
bon du coup il a choisi d'échanger
videmment ce qui est peut-être pas le
meilleur choix
ouais ça ensemble est bizarre ça quand
même parce que sur à sion ces trois
peut-être qu on sera obligé de bloquer
et auquel donc 10 ans et 3 on peut
pousser ces deux après ça a l'air
d'aller en fait sous le sceau pions va
être très très embêtant pour les mains
mais bon on a pas que ça du coup mais
non mais j'ai beaucoup pas anna peut
mettre sa tour en des sels peut-être bon
alors passer son cavalier qui nous parle
peut être aussi mettre le cavalier en b
5 mais bon s'ils ont aussitôt qu'on
déplace le cavalier il y aura il y aura
ces trois donc 1
donc la tour 17 on est vraiment de faire
ça c'est sûr mais le prononcé qui à tour
ses 7 et sa propre aux échanges de tous
mais c'est pas forcément au top ont donc
surtout en échange de tout on n'a
vraiment pas envie de le faire ici on
sera obligé de revenir à la maison et
c'est pas génial surtout plats y aura il
y aura la prison est sentie
ouais le coup le fond contre la casse et
en c'est vrai c'est vrai donc c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas vraiment eu peur de ça
mais mais quand même on aimerait bien ne
pas avoir à jouer contre contre en pions
on sait en c2 ok ok ok donc c'est
qu'elle peut même il changer son fou
pour le cavalier et c2 essayé de prendre
le contrôle des quinze hommes b5 et des
mais en pratique je sais pas si c'est
possible
ouais donc c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait
toujours ses six d'abord pour pouvoir
passer sans caillan c7 ouais ouais donc
là c'est ce qu'elle veut faire
j'imagine il reste pas beaucoup de temps
ci à yuya auquel prend ok je prends
après casser cette logique au le temps
vient de s'écouler
donc ça veut dire ça sera la dernière
partie et après ils savent ça passe
quand même 3 + 2 c'est la dernière
partie de 5-plus s'en est lassé
c'est l'heure du froid plus de ça c'est
la partie finale
donc là je pense que c'est déjà un gros
avantage pour les noirs si il arriva si
elle arrive à le faire correctement
peut-être ici fait retour des trois
suites ou voie b 3 me du coup l'ol qui
brille toujours ses 5 août où l'on voit
les samoa csaba on a fait on a fait ça
marche pas trop surtout avec le temps
qui lui est là ça va être chaud là c'est
même s'il arrive à sauver la nuit le
savez bien
avec ce temps là
tu as donc elle veut répéter les peut
pas répéter les mots ça m'a enfin i'm in
the band à la pendule a pas voulu
répéter rigaux elle a perdu autant
c'était long c'est tellement baisse
qu'elle a fait c'était comme ça elle a
pété les plombs comme ça et après
laféroise et 5 alors qu'il avait 11
secondes attendue plutôt que juste de
répéter le coup avec tout leur sens que
c'est parce qu'elle a voulu faire ici
c'est super bizarre
ok bon bah dommage pour elle est du coup
alain gagne donc à la a4 et me contre 2
me et c'est l'heure de la pause vu que
le temps vient de s'écouler et ce sera
l'heure de passer en trois plus de
maintenant donc vu que ça pose moi aussi
j'aime faire une petite pause et je
serai de retour temps s'inquiète quand
les parties vont reprendre donc à tout
alors je suis de retour et les parties
ont repris aussi donc c'était une
anglaise voilà c'était ça le début cette
mauvaise bon très très fermé tout ça en
général y a des plans pour les blancs
les noirs des poussées 1,6 bessin et que
aussi fou cod4 c'est possible mais bon
jouer h4h tant que c'est un peu bizarre
dans cette variante mai mais pour moi
mais ça peut jouer à part moi aussi
on peut-être peut-être des plans du
style un cavalier là c'est peut-être
possible suivi de m6
tel 06 décembre possible parce que ça
peut se tenter
ok caïds et 4 mais du coup ce cas ce
pion peut-être et de femmes si on fait
qu'elle ait des cinq peut-être pu
utiliser ça ça avait du coup il est bien
l échange de cavalli croquenots faux pas
elle le fait par les hoquets
telles qu'elles menacent de faire f 6 2
5 ouais c'est encore mieux je pense
parce que les menaces et les 6,5 le fou
est enfermé et du coup là il ya cavagne
droit qu'avait lieu trois années sur flu
premier 3 des premiers 3 il faut prendre
b2
toujours à deux peut-être celui de
racine
mais bon ça n'empêche pas trop on ya
quand même si les boues noir veut le
faire un dessin qu'elles peuvent l'autre
jour apprend pc sur d'improbables si ce
n'était pas un souci
donc là il ya un pion passé c'est simple
ça marche pas les doigts mais un peu je
tentais quand même c'est simple prêt
parce que là il ya pas à ces pièces pour
reprendre il faudra mettre le la dame là
ouais ça peut se tenter mais beaucoup
pensent que c'est pas c'est pas vraiment
un peu la cpi sur les tarifs pour
réellement le cas il peut même pas
bouger parce qu'il ya faut prendre des
quatre salaires vraiment fiable 5 qui
arrive d'amd d'eau dans une vidéo aussi
qui est possible on s'entend dans
certains cas
la toujours aussi attaque ça donc c'est
à dire c'est le tour ne peux pas trop
bouger parce qu'on préfère ça pour
attaquer
faut défendre pour défendre le pion je
vais pour elle réveillée autant ici
c'est bizarre sur le coup il a fait elle
veut faire caler des cinq à marans mais
ça ferait en fait c'est un petit crack
arrive on dirait super bizarre son choix
en plus ils à tours ça devient tour
sadouki simon qui va manger le fou je
vous prends des quatre aussi qui
arrivent à tremblant craquer moulouya
ok ouais bah c'est aussi ça va aussi ça
c'est très bien pour les noirs sa flopée
5,7 bienvenus
bon bah y gagnent autant org donc
c'était assez logique donc la gugga
seront relativement petit à petit 2025
donc ça c'est la même que ça c'est pas
la règle en fait non au lieu de venir en
fuite et il va à prions c3 ce qui est un
peu c'est un peu mieux
c'est un peu préférable pas mais ok
beaucoup lui donc apparemment elle
ajouté prévenant qu un avion ou alors
c'est juste une ligne féminine marrante
ne tentez de ferrer ont alors mon
passage la tour avec tours h3 et la
mettre en f3 la tourache pas ça a l'air
aussi pas mal pour protéger le blocus en
c3
ouais donc tafourah pour contrôler sa
bon c'est toujours possible de prendre
bien sûr mais c'est vrai que ça aide pas
dans les noirs du coup vu qu aura le
clouage sur le son le cavalier donc il
vaut mieux pour eux de juste continuer
leur développement
bien sûr c'est pas possible de prendre
ses cinq passes qui aura 85
donc ce puits on n'est pas des bas
prenable donc on peut juste continuer le
développement normalement kbc 5 kayak du
coup ça arrangerait laprise prenable
enfin salle andré le pion canal parce
que à ce moment là sur calais pendant 5
il y aurait ses promesses avec jacques
séguéla la dame pour ça sera un petit
souci
ok alors sur ces fronts des cats que se
passe-t-il c'est ça la question
amelia peut-être dame amy adams cache
quoi en bonne voie il ya ta mère
katherine
c'est une grossière de ça il ya les
fenêtres au la table au dommage dommage
dommage dommage car ça gagne direct
parce que le seco met donc le cahier
peut pas bouger
t'avais qu'à c'était fini archifaux est
sur m6 il y avait la prise donc d'un
mètre 4 et 6 prises à prendre le québec
dommage dommage dommage
abbas a pour sa part fini leurs gaffes
et là elle a même pas bougé son royal
aurait pu brûler sont rangés 8 après
sortir ton cahier avec elle en est 5e
mais n'a pas fait du coup là il fait ça
il ne repart gaffé et là d'un f4 d'alger
6 tous là tout à l'air de gagner donc
est la fille d'un logiciel c'est bien il
a trouvé le gain bail parce que bien sûr
c'est où tout est flou et c'est là
d'ailleurs assez marrant hein tout est
absolument tout est flou il n'y a aucun
moyen de défendre ou ce pion à vii
si on le pousse bien sûr y est là juste
là prise sur white ont fait avant et
après d'un problème d'un 3e
ouais juste d'un problème cette terre
quand je sais ça l'air d'être de très
moche très moche d'en prendre pour un
bouge d'un congé cet surtour g8 il ya
fou prend 2,7 qui va gagner il a tout
mangé dit
donc là je pense qu'elle peut que lynne
harpin d'abandonner ouais elle a vu l a
bien vu donc surtout retour 8
il y aura foule habillera pardon tours
et sète qui créera des broutilles retour
est plutôt osé c'est bien en appel c'est
très bien
elle pas encore essayé de se défendre
avec des pincettes mais bon ça ça
s'ajuste ça rallonge en plus des choses
mais c'est tout je pense que le résultat
ne changera pas
ok donc elles vont emmener son carillon
f406 salaire normal même kf4 la s'alarme
salaire bien ouais c'est ce qu'elle a
fait c'est le coup le plus le plus c'est
fini juste parce que tueur cavalli
cahier des 5 on peut prendre la tour en
huit d'impro caillou 6 leroy bougeant
ses huit iata de ses sept matches donc
c'est juste finir mon avis un peu
abandonné il ya vraiment rien à y faire
et surtout pour la fuite il yad'un prend
d'un bouge et il faut prendre cette le
fou n'est pas prenable
ok elle a trouvé en coûte défense fufu
des cinq donc voyons voir si ce qui se
passe
oui donc cavani prend ça à l'air bien en
plus on peut pousser ou six ans on
pousse juste six ans fait bon hockey l'a
pas fait annonce ainsi fait tour à tour
f cell c'est fini c'est fini
bon pas bien joué du coup bien jolie
anna enfin anna vraiment et lui laisse
aucune chance à l'un est très forte en
en baisse je pense qu'elle a l'air
d'être une très bonne joueuse
ok donc sinon c est la jouer un peu
bizarrement la joue gauche hollande à sa
a ok donc bon sas a transposé dans une
espèce de lempdes au feu sauf qu'elle a
commencé avec ses quatre premiers au
milieu je sais pas pour des anglais
après le tas quelques essayer aussi de
pousser et de pousser le 4 peut-être ou
alors non plus tôt à 3 pour empêcher les
sa tête repoussée b4 bon ok je n'avais
ce que je disais
ok donc surprise cavaliers prend y aura
peut-être eu 5 et le fou à sortir en
cinq
ouais ça a l'air de marcher ça
km et 4 ne s'attaque pas d'âme mais
savait pas grand chose d'autre on fait
juste bouger en e2 et après chasser le
cas ben ali je vois pas de quoi intérêt
de ce coup franchement oued ambiance
même si très bien ok je sache donc mais
dont on sent que la dame elle a un peu
marre été assez embêtant je pense
qu'elle aurait peut-être dû venir à eux
deux mais bon ça devrait aller quand
même qu'elle peut faire à 3 et après
faire des trucs du genre
fufu jestin qui a aidé sa de bras les
pénuries
salut bloc
donc vous n'êtes pas très bavard
aujourd'hui je vois pas mes yeux
ouais là je regardais pas trop le tchad
du coup vu qu'il n'y avait pas de
commentaire mais du coup là si j'ai
loupé des trucs à l'ordre alors on ne se
voyait pas ne soyez pas énervé pour moi
ok donc cavalier prend assez normal
répond pas pouvoir arriver en d5 donc
donc là si la dame bouge ça a l'air
d'aller devrait y avoir des trucs mais
bah disons d'un faux problème s'il faut
prendre qu'à elle et des saintes le four
pavant je sais tu sais il n'y a pas trop
de soucis surtout à cause du courage
donc c'est pas ça par un très gros voilà
cai dessin qui aura le fou qui est
repartir à angers 7 ou même dix huit
mois lord il a bien 18 chez ba c'est
bizarre ça me paraît bizarre ou 18 ha
parce qu'ils les tic sur fou j'ai c'est
qu'il ya cahier g5 là pour ça il a par
an il dit que les changes c'est bien au
lait blanc mais il faut des huit ça me
paraît super bizarre parce que ça prend
la place des tours moi je prends moi je
jouerai pas trop ce point ok donc la
lune les bains ont fait damas deux pour
défendre ce pion c'est bizarre choix
très bizarre la dame est pas forcément
bien placé on a deux mais quasiment pire
place y en a deux que qu'elle était en
bien donc bon que j'imagine elle veut
faire cailler des cinq continents
culture mais elle aurait pu le faire
tout de suite
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression sapin vous
pouvez aller valait mieux faire cailler
les 4 et 6 parce que du coup sûr samedi
qu'elle peut me faire caillasser 5
on met peut-être sur calais c5 qui aura
lieu rock avec des quatre mois peut-être
que ça marche
voilà 7 quel point les psys suivi de
cahiers des 5
au québec quatre donc là qu'il écarte ça
doit se tenter ça doit être vrai je
pense
anglaise
j'ai l'impression taddéï à des gros
trucs là alors là je pense que c'est un
gars donc tout va fabriquer six passes
alors tout récent congrès ce que les
noirs peut pas entendre oui mais du coup
il ya en fait on peut faire saisissent
ça on empêche le fou de revenir en g2
mais après on fera on fera des trucs du
genre cavaliers 3 ou alors d'am dam à
sera peut-être ouais ça c'est bien aussi
ça c'est bien aussi mon but on peut
prendre le pion et ça c'est top ça c'est
top
et en plus à n'importe quel moment on
peut aussi faire cs il faut avoir les
idées sur les fronts
c'est ce qu'il va faire ok
aulas attend elle a donné son som amis
non mais n'avait pas trop de gens
battent bas elle avait pas le choix a
été obligé de donner sans fumée you free
et continue en corner c'est beau d'avoir
de l'espoir dans ce genre de position
avec chinois réussir avec les blancs
pardon c'est beau d'espérer mais du coup
ça marchera pas trop aussitôt que la
tour bouge laquelle il sera en plus et
c'est d'un an mais deux
en plus avec 3 secondes l'avant à la
pendule j'ai pas trop ce qu'elle cherche
le yoyo lien voilà encore abandonné et
c'est assez c'est assez logique
ok repos cannes donc c'est la première
fois qu'on voit ça
bon me semble qu'on apprend vite à aucun
ok donc là c'est la vigne avec ses 5 qui
est bon en gros si les blancs essayer de
garder sion en faisant bkc 3 ça marche
pas trop il ya toujours des moyens de
pas de faire des à s'imposer comme ça
donc c'est pour ça qu'il va pas essayer
de garder pions mais ont poussé à 3
bécasses sauvegarder les pions c'est
encore plus bizarre je trouve pas ce que
c'est ça fait bizarre pour rien mais dès
qu'elle peut faire des trucs du genre
four b2 qu'elle peut se développer comme
ça
donc c'était facile
donc là et menacent de prendre mais ce
n'est pas une grosse menace est parce qu
en plus est juste sortir ' on peut faire
d'un monde à mes yeux deux sait pas on
s'en fiche un peu de solutions surtout
que si elle prend mes cahiers prendre
après on va faire des d'amal 5 des trucs
comme ça et on sera très content ici
segal peut-elle sas tente pour essayer
de taper point de la table hier le
centre noir ouais ça va pas mal parce
qu'elles feront que les profs ou deux
fait un petit roeulx qu'après mais
c'était aussi de crier en plus isolé
pour les noms en prenant des 5
ouais donc là peut-être rock pete rock
et au bon c'est cette position
elle est très égal je dirais pas que les
chansons plus d'un côté que de l'autre
elle juste très égal à inventer qui a
des d'un bébé trois équipes est arrivé
est bon dit d'abord faut faire tirage
bien sûr pour défendre des cars f2 mais
un prêt de dix ans sur sur foule a
peut-être d'am-dam mais trois belles
choses surtout s'ils sont à b5
donc ouais attend sur sur food essent
temps qu'est ce qui se passe au fond de
ce type sont lourdes il aime pas troupes
non qui dit que ja il disait qu'il y
avait c'est prendre des 5 suivi de la
ps3 du coup elle a pas fait ça la fête
des 4 des cas c'est super bizarre
cavalier catalan bien ouais ça va être
des tons un choix si bizarre surtout que
là on peut faire des f4 juste des
facettes donne vraiment l'avantagé aux
blancs je pense alors qu'ils avaient une
structure de pion à c'est assez normal 8
aurait pu faire des trucs du genre tour
des huit aussi pour garder leur centre
est là elle pousser des quatre ça attéby
vraiment je trouve donc ça n'a pas trop
de sens en plus la haye où il peut y
avoir est 5e ces cinq pardon dans le
futur elle aussi contrôlée ces
diagonales
ça l'a vraiment d'être une bonne chose
pour les blancs seings d'enfer dans
certains cas aussi peut-être faire dam
des deux essais de doubler comme ça
parfois d'oublier la dame et la tour sur
le sur le pion des 4 donc ouais c'est
bien ça ça leur top savais pas ce que je
pense que ceux qui ont des cartes qui va
juste et splendeur il va juste tombés
tout simplement peut même juste les
retours des gens ici et après sur sur
fou 17 si on veut pas se fouler cette si
on veut on peut prendre en d4
ok alors le pion en russie c'est aussi
très faible et puis à bord des idées à
du genre dame de aussi pour arriver avec
cinq filles de créer des preuves dames 2
donc le pion aux oeufs kfk venait pas
prenable parce qu'il ya toujours faut
prendre achète donc sa verte est bien
secours en plus la carte est simple et
bien contrôlée donc jamais d'un dessin
est donc là dessus on veut on peut
on peut faire d'un match correct mais
bon ça sert plus à grand chose parce que
le plan est bon pour high épouser mon
fils tant qu'on ne sera obligé de
revenir revenir aux cartes peut-être
faut prendre tout reprendre bon le plan
des cartes là toujours faible mais il
faut trouver un moyen de l'attaqué
tadam g4
cavalli beau j'attaque la tour avec le
cahier peut passer en attaque
ou alors on peut aussi pousser les 5
pouces et 5 salaires top vraiment top
si la prison reprend après y aller il ya
des beaucoup l'idée sourd à chis et bien
sûr le put on ne peut pas pousser parce
qu'on leur pensée tout
et s'il n'a fait rien du tout on prend
simplement à ces deux pièces donc ok
elle a pris donc à veiller pont c'est
normal leroy bouge mais bon c'est vrai
que le roi du coup il est vite c'est à
cette menace de cahiers prend h6 mais on
n'a pas besoin de faire ça en tant que
juste faire d'un match 4 comme l a fait
et après il ya toujours désigné comme
cavaye prend 1,6 si la fois dans
certains cas peut-être aussi cavalier 7
c'est sa piètre aussi cool
oh oui ça c'est bien saluons mais je me
demande s'il va peut-être par le mieux
que ça bon là peut-être pas tort
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elle a louée à la jeunesse
a ouais c'est bien ça donc là ça va vite
parce que toutes les données seront ils
sont en mal autant le beau sacrifice
très joli
bongo est un joli matelas je vous laisse
chercher mais c'était sa baisse et elle
était très jolie
ok bon babel partie lors de la parole
anna donc 8 admis à 2 min occupa pauvre
pauvre 1 ap
passez pas tout la pauvre hall
ioulia pardon c'est pas top pour elle
ok alors
bon bah ça c'est ça c'est une juste 11/6
bizarre avec b3 ok donc ça ensemble est
bizarre mais bon j'imagine qu'elle
connaît bien
je crois que le gallia s'est bien
préparée à vendre avant ce tournoi en
tout pas là l attente est ok bon c'est
le signal assez connu enfin c'est ça
c'est connu que pousser aussi ça donne
pas grand chose en fait ouais il ya 2,5
l'a peut-être mal un truc c'est que les
noirs peuvent pas faire grand petit robe
donc c'est un peu embêtant même qu'elle
ait des cartes qui arrive même taille et
les casques aussi et peut-être aussi
poussé le 5 le pion c'est sain peut être
faible peut-être mais ça passera ou ceux
ci donc d'un français catway ces
attaques le concept simple si la dame ou
jean bessis son archaïsme dessin qui
arrive qui sera des petits trafics donc
b6 soit b6 logique grand subi de
descartes salaire bien ouais bon suivi
de descartes et gel j'aimerais bien qu'à
la fin ça parce que c'est intéressant de
voir ce qui se passe aux caisses elle
l'a fait c'est cool fm a écouté donc là
on menace vraiment pousser des cas des
quatre est donc le seul moyen de
l'empêcher sera de faire feu 5 mais
après tout rien on continue à menacer h
théâtre aussi c'est intéressant donc là
peut-être kebab et va essayer de faire
mon rock
webb a essayé au club
ok donc key des 5 mai qui est des
singles parus grand chose ne se passe
après après d'anne decis donc ouais
c'est pas top pour les blancs c'est en
fait elle a un peu loupé son attaque le
trop et là on peut louper parce qu'on
aimerait bien posséder quatre mais c'est
pas lui c'est plus possible maintenant
que le roi est bien cachée or on ensuite
c'est malheureusement ça plus possible
aucaigne h 4 donc elle va elle a voulu
ouvrir la clown h d'abord en prenant et
après caillage 4 c'est assez intéressant
donc là l'origine de défendre serait
bien sûr de faire tout rachid parce que
j'ai cinq ça ne marche pas parce qu'il
ya qu'avait dit ceci soit les occasions
qu'elle a bien fait ou rachida hockey or
elle a fait tour ashes donc que faire
ici peut-être pas juste revenir en fait
c'est mieux c'est moi je sais triste
mais c'est nécessaire
malheureusement parce que j'imagine que
là il y aura toujours à 8 8,2 g 5
ça a l'air vraiment vraiment très
difficile
donc là on attaque le cavalier après
peut-être tu auras g4 ouais vous aussi
sa mère vient aussi chercher leurs dames
s'il a d'abord à 6 elle sera enfermée
totalement il y aura juste 3bis 8 avril
y aura des petites idées comme kvm et 4
donc il vaut mieux qu'elle reste reste à
des endroits où ce rêve et se fera pas
en terme et donc la tête mais nord ont
des idées comme f5 celui de g4 ou alors
plutôt gg 4-way cahier des quatre aussi
c'est pas vrai
ouais bien sûr c'est pas possible de
prendre parce qu'on ya la fonction
formation sur la dame et le cavalier
donc ce cas il n'est pas prenable et
sikhs avaient lieu deux bâtiments là il
y aura su rend fou g4 qui créera des
bourgs problème je garde ça la fout g4
ça l'a vraiment bien
dans le pot 4 j'allais dire d'avocats
c'est super beau mais à cause de faux f5
donc c'est lors de coups ça n'existera
jamais eh ben elle a notamment empêché
avec fodé 5 maintenant donc ça a l'air
vraiment très difficile pour elle ment
je pense que c'est quasiment perdu déjà
ça m'a l'air en tout cas avait presque
perdu parce qu'il y aura eu ras
détourage denis g4 plein d'idées ou ont
bien sûr ses pions là on les touche fois
ci en plus de 4 il y aura dame prend des
4 mai au plus tôt des trucs du genre g4
et après fou et f3 ou peut-être tour h2k
on a dit ok c'est quoi son nom déjà son
idée c'est de faire ce soir elle va
faire foule faut 4 mais surtout auquel
j'avais annoncé quatre noms takabox
d'abord faire b5 et après coup et quatre
bons à l'europe aux échanges aux dames
au caire
tu vas y va progresser ses seins pour sa
part hausse est trop sympa de la part de
l'un est là et la finul alors que alors
qu'ils étaient totalement gagnante elle
le savait d'ailleurs qui était gagnante
je pense mais elle a accepté d'annuler
juste pour donner envie parce qu'elles
sont du même pays du coup je pense que
c'est pour ça oui ok c'est c'était sympa
c'est un bon beau geste de fair-play
surtout que les bouts elle a beaucoup à
l'avant soit au niveau score donc elle
peut se permettre de faire des trucs
comme ça
cette école c'était cool donc et niveau
niveau temps là il reste un peu moins de
dix minutes après ça serait leur du
bullet déjà donc ça arrivera vite
ok c'est qu'il ya cavaliers g3 pour
empêcher des truites du genre caillage 5
ou alors qu'à veiller à froid c'est plus
normal j'imagine pour faire un caillou 5
en effet on remet la dame là on atteint
15,7
tant mieux ça que ça peut arriver
peut-être
j'ai trois outils
ouais bien 10 il ya beaucoup d'idées je
pense que la pollution est déjà un
avantage juste pour les beaux dessins
que j'aime bien c'est le coût que
j'aurai choisi sûrement
ok donc là il n'y a pas trop de choix
pour le cavalier joue cavalier obligé de
revenir à la maison
il se remet sur la case de départ et
pour du roi des idées comme un fou rouge
après pousser les pions
peut-être dalloz dames 2 au 6 mai à
prévenir on g4
ok alors là il n'y a qu'à yat sen qui se
prépare mais c'est un second possible je
pense que là il ya vraiment trop ça
blesse dans le camp des noirs ça sera
assez facile de de prendre l'avantagé
ici c'est qu'on peut mettre tenter des
tours sion pour essayer d'ouvrir le
travail c4 ou alors en cas de prise de
reprendre dommage car c'est bien ouais
ouais faut g5 c'est même possible ici
pour prendre avantage du fait que vous
ne peut pas prendre bien sûr vous pour
marcher ça c'est une grosse erreur à
cause de cavalli g8 sinon ça on n'en
parle pas mais où les cinq ça peut être
pas mal sur brock bien sûr on comprend
le cavalier donc le but c'est de prendre
le kv7 en cas de grand
c'est juste d'empêcher grand fête est
aussi de faire flouer sinon certains cas
donc je pense que c'est vraiment très
jolie qu'aux très très jolie donc fuji
simple disons que la fif et ampoules du
genre ah ok elle n'a pas fait dommage
j'aurais bien aimé voir ça mais bon ça
c'est super aussi bien sûr c'est super
on peut faire b4 par exemple ou alors
pendant h6 bien sûr le gros rock c'est
pas très sympa vraiment possible
c'est pas beau du tout d'ailleurs il ya
peut-être même une dame prend 1,7 sur
mon rock ola ils menacent ou abaissent
fans ou là là c'est une grosse menace à
un four si on fait pas gaffe la force
est donc on est obligé de prendre avec
le cavalier pour la gaf 1 au lagaf ya
fouet cette là qui gagnent les dames m
c'est moi je la barre de la nasa bon
elle est pour survivre elles obligées de
faire cailler prend 1,6 fou prend
effacement la f1 il donne pas madame
quoi ouais bah du coup elle donna dans
le même temps c'est moi je suis sa
machine est moche du coup du coup et va
perdre quel avec l tactics
bon ça c'est ça c'est sacré avantage
pour les noirs ça sera assez facile de
prendre encore on encore plus gros
avantage ici faire des trucs du genre
une fois 4e bougera de faire des trucs
du genre comme l'a jamais prendre c'est
encore pire fallait que je lui avais
fait lit-on sur l'échiquier
alors que leila aucune chance de tenir
n'a aucune chance de tenir un peu quand
est-ce qu'elle peut tenir ses pions là
avec fouet cavaliers c'est pas possible
il aura juste d'un monde à ma carte par
exemple qui est va venir en bien et pas
attaquer un truc comme ça
elle l'a pas fait mais bon ça ça risque
quand même de gagner
ouais bah ils attaquent le qui ont ces
trois sur cabaye ou deux il y avait des
talents d'homme c'est ok ok ouais mais
bon vu le vu le temps d'un nom phase
finale par le cavalier ça ok alors c'est
fini
c'est fini mais il reste plus que quatre
minutes 4 minutes et ça sera l'heure de
début mai et déjà déjà leur doublette ça
va vite dit donc oui et j'espère en
bullet ioulia réussir en un peu mieux ça
serait bien d'avoir encore faire un des
bons matches quand même essayer de
remonter un peu le sport même si on n'y
croit pas trop
anna commence un peu à craquer donc donc
auront si jamais tu t'es con bullet et
leur a vraiment des chances
donc ça c'est la dernière partie du coup
le temps le temps c'est pas assez pour
pour commencer une nouvelle partie après
ça
voilà donc là elles lancent tous ses
pions
key a acheté 1 ça peut être intéressant
mon futur donc faut qu'elle fasse gaza
faut qu'elle fasse gaffe à ça donc que 3
way 3 wes alors ça va elle a bien marché
5 l5 alors attends escape a eu quatre
non il n'y a pas de cap parce que katia
cavaillé prend 1,4 et celle ci a trouvé
la gaffe et elle l'a même pas vu qu'ils
savaient que ces faits que y avait eu
cinq sabouret réfléchit non mais n'est
sûr car jusqu'à y penser non c'est pas
en ce moment où l'on a et la drire ont
pensé que c'était que c'est tim cup ça
se trouve fois que la panse ses plaies
qu'elle a gaffé
c'est là oublient qu'ils avaient cueilli
feront parce que du coup c'est super
bizarre de faire b4 bon j'imagine elle
veut prendre 5
tu as aimé du coup là il se retrouve mal
le fait d'avoir le cul en bk je suis pas
sûr que ce soit une bonne chose bol
ouais ça ça a l'air vraiment bien pour
les noirs je pense qu'il peut se
développer assez assez facilement comme
ça cette revue du genre fois ci c'est
aussi ça peut se faire
c'est vraiment bien ça c'est vraiment
idéal de 4 mais eux car trop faire gaffe
parce que ma déjà fin le fou et
l'armement une fois comprendre à leucate
nférieure parce que ça te donne la casse
dès qu'un truc mais ça peut-être d'un
qu'on peut y penser ça peut se vanter
qu'elle est proche de suivi de 2,4 ouais
bah c'est ce qu'elle a fait ok a donc à
l'afrique les cavaliers donc maintenant
avait quatre c'est un peu toujours ceux
tentés mais moi ça peut se vanter en
fait le 4 ou alors ce qu'elle a à faire
ce qu'elle a fait c'est bien aussi
tam des six mètres
joe g force que lors des 10 sur 10 ha
mais je peux pas en fête eid x avait que
7 passable c'est potable ah bah ça il
dit que c'est clairement mieux que j'ai
4 ans bas puisque g4 helix une grosse
gaffe parce qu'il y avait quatre le
temps s'est écoulé du coup c'était bien
la dernière partie de beats et après ça
passe quand bullet comment commandes
comme on l'avait pensé
c'est terrible pour les blancs ça c'est
terrible le roi ne peut même pas requis
tranquillement parce que qui va se faire
a explosé ces taux qui va faire rock il
y aura y aura foule et simple par
exemple ou alors un truc qui vont
arriver là en plus ici on ignore peut
faire cailler détroit s'ils volent si
elle veut aussi d'un mandat me 5
peut-être ces terribles time to carry
calé trois ça me paraît pas mal aussi
on n'a pas de sens mais je pense
qu'elle prend 1,4 au période compliquée
pour 1,4 à y aller pour la garde c'est
moche on vote
elle l'a pas fait mais ne l'a pas fait
c'est bien c'est bien pour alain n'a
peut-être dame s'est vite pour attaquer
le cavalier c'est le cavalier repart
alliot marie à bord des trucs du genre x
h trois ans peut-être
et aussi lui reste pas beaucoup de temps
à ilo ya c'est très mauvais niveau tant
poil faut être un salaire bien fois je
croise à la hausse il vient d'un mot si
c'est bien aussi pour protéger cette
chance avec ben ils voulaient attaquer
le cavaliere
on sent que la caf ouais donc là il a
juste gagné hockey bombe a bien joué à
anna donc et le fini biblique avec eux
aussi avec 10 points 4 et maintenant ça
sera l'heure du bullet donc c'est la
ligne finale l'a donc voilà donc là il y
aura une pause et ça reprendra dans
quelques minutes le banc cinq minutes
donc vu que cela pose lui aussi prendre
la pose et je reviens tout de suite a
dit
ok donc ça a repris elle je suis de
retour donc voilà j'espère qu'ils
viennent de jeu c'est de commencer je
crois que je crois que c'est le cas
bioware ce qui s'est passé où ils ont
même score donc c'est bien c'est bien
ils viennent juste de commencer en effet
donc peut-être carrier cinq essais 4
donc voyons voir d'abord le début donc
c'était le 4 et 6 6 ok ça s'est passé
comme ça ok ça marche ça marche ça
marche
bon le bullet le bullet un habitant ça
va très très vite donc la d5 c'est pas
mal ça contre on a cassé quatre c'est
pour ça qu'elle a fait b3 pour pouvoir
la contrôler aussi mais je pense que je
préfère un peu la position des noirs
c'est un peu plus simple à jouer quelles
et 17,7 bien vu mais je crois qu'il y
avait tout prend 1,8 en fait tout prend
8 buts on prend et après la dame devait
rentrer en c est ça qu elle pas mal mais
elle n'a pas joué au haut bas à daggar
fauquet monde ici j'aurais pu jouer
autre chose mais là elle a fait une
gaffe est la plus posée si ce n'est
faire le filon des simples c'est ça qui
équivaut au mais il ya toujours deux ans
la bomba les bullet c'est bon c'est
prévisible qui est beaucoup de gaffes
donc en ce moment on s'en doute un peu
donc il a poussé hk qui arrive à
peut-être peut-être d'un france et f5 ça
me surprennent qu'elle n'avait pas fait
en fait un problème c'est qu'ici parce
que vous hsa pas trop de sens surtout
pas elle arrive à défendre à un sénat
aux anneaux bon là c'est mieux non c'est
vraiment très nul cette fois ils m'ont
très égale g5 c'est bien vu peut-être
que maintenant et peut avoir des chances
qu'on fait avec d'impro hkc après s'il
réussit à pousser justice aux condoms et
bien donné sa dame en noir le craquage
moins ça leur bombe à la pauvre où il ya
ça ne se passait pas bien pour elle
mais bon le budget le budget des gaffes
de partout c'est ça c'est ça cette
révision
ok à carte b4 maintenant il a cassé 4
pour les blancs donc et préfèrent fêter
ses quatre ans elle peut aussi revenir
avec son fou peut-être parce que le
fonds ne sait pas grand-chose dans des
lieux du coup 15e 2 pour contrer le
cahier ans s'écarte c'est normal aussi
peut-être pousser
elle a remis l armée le fond mais deux
pas se serait que le fruit d' absolument
rien papa bonjour rien du coup alors ok
donc aussi et pousserait 5 ça sera une
heure je pense parce qu'ils auraient
payé des cinq lecavalier sera assez fort
ok pas c'est bien parce que le cahier
pouvait plus rien on dézingue maintenant
à cause du fou bas il ya peut-être pour
tours b 1 qui arrive je fous b3 aussi
peut-être pour défendre ce qu'ils ont et
c'est ce qu'elle a fait procès à cinq
leur qualité 5 mai à ce moment là il y
aura tout repenser tout france et 5 1
mais tout repenser sa voix non c'est
bien en soi mais leur dilemme pas en
fait ils n'aiment pas prendre et surtout
humains partout en france et 5
il dit qu'en fait il avec ail et ses
trois usines mes lordi il a bien fou à 4
ha bah oui il ya mis à flot à 4 pour
gagner pour gagner ça donc ok nombre de
bulles est qu il ya peut-être aux
avantages pour anna du coup mais non
c'est repasser du condamnable parce
qu'elle va essayer de faire des trucs du
genre tour béant où y'a même pas tout
rouge et 3 parce qu'il ya la veille la
dame en l'air ou là c'est fini sa course
ici d'hommes
enfin il y avait en plus d'un premier 3
c'est moi ok bon bah bien jouer encore
une fois alain donc elle gère vraiment
bien
a donc je vous la même une que d'hab
avec avec b six fours if it away elle
toujours la même
h5 peut-être way
tu avais pas beaucoup juste un coquet
ouais donc là on peut même pousser hc
sion veut
wayne on sait déjà c'est déjà gagnant je
pense alors dit il aime bien le combat
en fait ils avaient bien ça fout c6
mieux que c'est chloé tour j'ai tour
c'est 8 et sait prendre des 5
parce qu'eux et ça gagne incluant potes
ça aurait été drôle matraques des haches
si celle-là jouer mais c'est un peu trop
tard maintenant parce que la tour n'a
plus ne contrôle plus h au petit
craquage or tout petit craquage donc là
mais non c'est redevenu un normal pour
les noirs surtout que la colombie est
ouverte
c'est pas si mal cette monde peut faire
des trucs comme ça aussi ça repart elle
ouais carrier 4 bafouer cette sagesse à
être vraiment parce que du coup ça
laisse admissible qu'on peut prendre ça
a été après faire cavalier et 6
ok du coup c'est ainsi qu'on aime bien
pour lui et pour alain
du coup ça arrivait de cafouillage pas
toujours tout retour sain et du coup ça
y est ça évite d'avoir des cas du coup
la donne mais bon ok ya je ne sais pas
trop il assure you à la prison en
justice oh il ya tout rend peut-être
hockey ne va pas du temps de prendre des
cas ça devrait marcher maintenant ça
court ça se trouve c'est nul ça ah ouais
d'aveux 5 et du coup il ya dame g3 qui
échangent mais prendre avec le piment
c'est bien parce que sinon il y avait la
fourchette si on fait avec le roi ouais
ça c'est bien du côté de nouveau du côté
de l' avantage de l'eau ou du coup de
dana
g4s ping archives
fait
et ces matches
bon alors il dira est en fait moins de
15 minutes et ça serait la fin donc je
pense que ça va être un peu difficile
pour eux pour ioulia de ce fou de
rattraper tous ces points perdus
donc ça sera encore en mettre assez
rapide il n'y aura pas de départage
ok donc là bas là ça a l'air pas mal
pour les noirs déjà fait pousser des cap
d'ail ils ont ils contrôlent le centre
l'âge est là aussi trop ce qui est sous
les blancs en fait c'est le cas il ne
peut pas vraiment sortir à cause du plan
c 3 qu'elle ait des 4 je me dois et
j'allais dire il serait lui le d'anttila
pas fou prend ces trois là il faut
prendre quelle époque et prendre des
cartes ça leur revient
un cas très peu car ça peut marcher ça
peut se tenter en tout cas mais
maintenant apparaitre l'a pas fait ok ça
c'est ça c'est joe si elle bouge le
cavalier le plan trois tombes ou alors
si elle prend le cavaly sera attaqué en
même temps que le pion et la structure
sera terrible ouvert à tous qui sera
attaqué le pion détroit le cas et c'est
trop alors qu on est de 4 c'est terrible
terrible être leucate bienvenus ça m'a
vu je pense que c'est le meilleur os est
de sauver sa un peu en tout cas
d'essayer sur dame 3 sur dame préfère
fois je crois
sa force à cinq a maintenant on a fait
h3 google je pense qu'elle aurait plutôt
dû faire flasher 3 et du coup sûr un
hashtag que l'on a pu tenter des trucs
du genre f3 ouais mais du coup la cacm
s'échauffent
ces chaussettes chaussures tout il ya
caïds et saint riquier donc là elle
tente des scènes de mogettes pion une
qu'elle peut être aidé 5
non c'est difficile
tour d un suivi de tournage fini ne pas
nous en empêche le sang avec ayew 2o
dure bataille et desagana tour bien
jouer encore une fois anna donc sans
ajout au but les demandes se montent on
est il reste au bon endroit 11 minutes
et 50 secondes dans mon coeur le match
se terminera bientôt donc bon elle joue
toujours la même à chaque fois c'est
marrant d'ailleurs ça a dit ça te sa
prépa spéciale pour ce match
mais même si ça se passe pas trop bien
pour elle elle continue à le jouer à
chaque fois
ok
donc peut-être dam des trois lacs avait
bougé après on peut faire débat moi je
crois en tête pour chasser le fou ou
alors ou alors poussé c4 ou alors mettre
le camion f4 peut-être aussi dans
certains cas poussés h6 hockey baker ça
c'est assez logique aussi fo est fondée
partie similaire à chaque fois mais mais
il ya toujours des différences ou
sherbrooke
c'est bizarre ça bon repas dans cette
position c'est aussi un peu ali allaient
dans la gueule de lyon mais parce que du
coup il ya peut-être aa 4 à 5 la celle
là c'est mort ces morts à 5 c c'est fini
je fonce
ok et peut essayer tous retrouveront
aussi pour essayer de rentrer on a sept
ça se tente
ouais ça se tente
tourbes et c'est peut-être qu'à et 17
après faut trouver un moyen de 1 mais on
peut faire tourner ça peut-être qu'elle
a déserté après fait retour à 7 est
doublé les détours sur la colonne
souvent là sur la rangée 7
mais bon elle n'a pas choisi ce plan
ainsi elle le fait maintenant à la tour
hassan j'imagine oui c'est ça c'est fini
ok donc là ça gagne aussi le qu on
achète si elle veut elle peut le prendre
c'est un assesseur raté que ça donne du
contre-jour nord ça en fait ça en donne
la peur revenir son cabas s'il peut
faire payer des 4 mai ouais en tout
passé - ces malentendus qu'avant surtout
blague elle descend au niveau tant elle
revient occasion en même temps que ce
calcul que ce que ioulia adapté à calais
18 où il a accueilli 18 ta merde ça
c'est bien vu aussi well as a l'air
super ouais enfin c'est leur gagne pain
c'est là c'est moi c'est moi je crois
qu'avec cette c'est bien ah ben pâton du
couple est peut-être pas faire sa ba
hoku fallait vraiment pas faire ça alors
oula ça fait nul bon du coup ça ça fait
nul mais j'ai juste envie de regarder si
c'est passé en fait plus tôt a ici là
elle aurait dû faire autre chose proche
alors elle où elle aurait dû faire autre
chose ou alors même juste prendre
reprendre le chemin mais du coup la paf
et salle un peu gaffe et voyons voir si
l'espace est donc c'est nul
ok on joue pas c'est pas c'est pas un
mauvais résultat pour alan hope sûrs de
faire mieux vu le vul avance coeur
by ap tel tld saint flour pour occuper
la case d3 mais non celle là c'est plus
pareil
kohl a pris
piqué de ce bien venu pour arriver en q3
et ces quatre pays a baissé de la b5 et
après une brouille qu'elle avait eu
droit la pauvre ioulia se fait torturer
faux projet 4 qui arrive aussi
ouais
ok donc le set final devrait être
permettre davantage de soin leur tête
ils ont en plus en plus moi même mais
bon là c'est vraiment pas si simple faut
vraiment il faut vraiment chercher pour
les non
f5 qui arrive
pour baisser ça peut être pas mal je
prends après ça souvent
bon là il y aura des socios je pense
même 4 h 4 et des plantes qui te semble
tourbes et 4 aussi ça m'a peut-être ça
aussi on veut faire tour à sept si le
football donc mais peut-être pas prendre
en fait juste juste garder mais met leur
santé pour commencer à pousser les pions
ouais là on peut peut-être ou peut-être
même faire j'ai sahraouis tour à trois
c'est aussi bien vu ouais là c'est
vraiment bien on a fait ces quatre super
et ana a gagné
sais-tu voir la mine je pense que non la
changer l achat il d'amender sa de cette
fois tout elle trouve toujours des coups
bas oui
[Musique]
désolé pour le bruit à des feux
d'artifice devoir
désolé
voilà certaines des pétards je pense que
c'est plutôt des pétards bon hors du
coup c'est ce qu'on peut pousser à sa
banque
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait donc ça y
est difficile à tenir parce qu'il ya 6
et g5
bon entre les cages là je pense qu'il
reste maximum de partis parce que c'est
celle là est la dernière où là qu'est
promenade
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là et surprise
d'am dam des deux caisses et le diadème
f2 donc je sais pas je sais pas trop ce
qu'elle voit peut-être que centre agl je
suis pas trop ce qu'elle veut ferries à
obala la c5 peut-être pas celui du coup
le film en c3 va être en prise si ou
lire grâce à elle aura des chances
maintenant du coup ne l'a pas vu de moi
peut se cacher il ya peut-être four
siens qui arrive
ouais ça c'est bien aussi ce qu'elle a
fait donc là il ya toujours ces cinq qui
peut être embêtant
même en laye le web à elle le voit pas
oui donc ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
super pour les blancs des rouages de l a
enfin fait oh ben non
j'allais dire d'un préfet d'un messie
même ça ça marche quand même passé a
peur on pouvait se cacher le roi ah non
ça marchait pas il y avait foule suit
pas et là c'est mort six morts c'est
mort parce que la dame est la tour sont
montagne donc là c'est là c'est fini
bon la pauvre duo il ya il s'est fait
martyriser donc là si ses ennemis contre
4 ennemis j'aurais vraiment pas cru que
le score la différence de soi en serait
si grande
je pensais qu'ils avaient quand même en
niveau assez proche parce que ils
veulent y aller elle enfin la dga même
assez connue elle joue même à ses liens
donc mais bon bien sûr un an a été très
très forte mais je pensais que leur
niveau se rapprocher un peu plus que ça
mais bon ok donc là c'est ainsi en
espèce de système de londres
donc bien voir ce qui se passera donc
tant qu'on peut prendre faire food et 3
prendra aussi ok mais si on prend ces
cinq voire toujours des procès et 25
pour les noirs donc alors ça ça
d'ailleurs là il faut noter qu'il reste
moins de 30 secondes au times donc ça
sera clairement la dame rapporte donc
après cette partie ça sera la fin du
match vous et qu'il arrive fo prend
achète ça serait joli mais ça marche pas
malheureusement pas ce quimpérois prend
kabylie g5 un g6 sait ce qu'elle fait
mais ça ne marche pas parce que il ya
qu'à payer province indique donc ioulia
tente le tout pour le tout mais ça ne
marche pas en dire de là il peut être
essayer de faire d'amen detroit mais
quoi comme dira yake progrès cinq dames
g3 un peu tenté mais le roi c'est
schaerbeekois m6
donc là d'un match 4 on dirait que ça
fait peur mais en fait le roi se cache
on s'est tu
well as et la cgc encore quand vos
avantages pour un an
guerrier car c'est bien ouais tam
justice pour attaquer le pion au 6 mai
bune mamie on peut défendre très
facilement
au pis c'est pas si clair c'est pas
super mais même si les noirs ont il
devrait quand même avoir un bel avantage
la loi n'en sait pas c'est que l'arrêt
ne faut que j'analyse annoncé claire
hideout est à même de ce qui arrive
ouais ben ahmed de après qu'elle ait des
trois ça devrait être finie bientôt
aussi vite aussi c'est bien vu
la gaffe
ouais mais yu gamma perdante en nylon
temps ça soit possible
bon elle tente de se défendre elle
essaie vraiment mais bon cette finale
depuis on sait c'est pas possible
tokyo qui rament ensemble et 3 c'est là
c'est l'acier surtout elle a moins de
temps que son honneur ce avant que bon
elle veut avoir les nerfs pour continuer
sauf au nom pourrait laisser poitiers
continue ça c'est moche
bon j'espère qu'elle va abandonner crime
non mais ça c'est pas trop j'ai fait ce
qu'elle veut faire là le point continue
seul l accès s'il ya six ans n'a fait en
pattes ça aurait été drôle donc elle a
gagné ok donc adapte son score final 17
ennemis contre 4 ennemis donc c'est la
fin les parties sont finies donc voilà
donc juste pour le rappel ça s'est il
apparut ans donc j'ai juste le maître
comme ça
voilà donc ça ça les appariements donc
il reste plus qu'une ronde dépôt de la
première phase
donc c'est demain et c'est entre
fouillis farocki la favorite clairement
et bonnart mama doit donc oui fans bien
sûr c'est la numéro un mondiale du
joueur deux joueuses actives
maintenant je pense que c'est clairement
la favorite de ce tournoi en général et
elle joue demain donc on se retrouve
voilà ce moment pour regarder c'est
parti voilà et ça ça en fait la dernière
le dernier match de la phase finale
et sinon voici les le classement voilà
donc là c'est ce qui s'est passé donc
l'agglo a gagné blizzard a gagné
daniels a gagné aussi le match
d'aujourd'hui l'oeil qingli a gagné et
arica aussi stefanova aussi à gagner est
donc là enfin musi tout coup aussi donc
voilà donc c'est la fin donc merci
d'abord regardé j'espère que vous avez
apprécié les commentaires et on se
retrouve demain donc à nous